indignation en grande bretagne après la
mort de lord mountbatten nouvel attentat
lire à bruxelles contre les soldats
anglais sécurité routière mesures très
sévères contre les chauffards décider
demain puis gangster arrêté à paris
depuis deux mois il creuser un tunnel
pour cambrioler une banque
là messieurs bonsoir l'angleterre choqué
déchaîné même contre les terroristes de
l'ira qui hier ont assassiné le dernier
héros de la vieille albion l'amiral
mangue betten et qui dans le même temps
massacrait 18 soldats au sud de belfast
l'angleterre donc se mobilisent une
réunion spéciale tout à l'heure à
downing street au tour dans l'âme
satcher leur tour aujourd'hui de deux
des membres de familles royales les plus
proches de l'amiral man battle le prince
charles qui était en vacances en islande
et puis le duc d'edimbourg qui lui était
en france au haras du pin des milliers
de télégrammes de condoléances parmi
lesquels ceux du pape et du président
giscard d'estaing et puis je vous le
disais ce long cri de vengeance
scandaient aujourd'hui par l'opinion et
les journaux britanniques
les titres de la presse aujourd'hui sont
très durs pour lire à témoin ce titre
l'express
c'est à tard du diable et les titres de
la presse de l'après midi sont encore
plus dur ce sont des [ __ ] titre ton
dans d'autres journaux
avec moi je crois que c'est la chose la
plus choquante de ces dix dernières
années c'est sanglant est horrible c'est
fou c'est complètement fou j'ai servi
sous ses ordres en birmanie et qu'est ce
que vous pensez de lire je ne peux pas
dire ce que je pense sont des tueurs des
assassins des tueurs vraiment c'est tout
ce qu'ils sont dits responsables
eh bien
lord mountbatten sera enterré la semaine
prochaine en grande pompe à l'abbaye de
westminster quant au gouvernement
britannique
après ce qui s'est passé après cette
attaque directe aux symboles de la
puissance britannique
il ne peux que redire sur l'attitude cet
après midi s'est tenue une réunion
restreinte de cabinet avec margaret
thatcher il y avait là le ministre de la
défense le ministre de l'intérieur
margaret thatcher a refusé il ya
quelques temps on se rappelle la
médiation des etats-unis pour le monde
l'internationalisation du conflit en
irlande du nord
batmag margaret thatcher ne pourra que
durcir son attitude contre le terrorisme
oui indignation renforcer cet après midi
par un nouvel attentat revendiqué lui
aussi par l'ira mais cette fois hors des
frontières du royaume uni et les îles
britanniques cela s'est passé à
bruxelles sur la grande place une
dizaine de personnes dont six militaires
britanniques ont été blessées à la suite
de l'explosion d'un engin les militaires
faisait partie d'un régiment une fanfare
qui allait se produire sur la grand
place de la capitale belge peut-être des
images dans le courant de ce journal
voilà donc à nouveau projeté en pleine
lumière le drame irlandais et le
terrorisme de ceux qui veulent libérer
de lutter toute présence britannique
on croyait le problème quelque peu en
sommeil pourtant rien n'a vraiment
changé depuis le début de la flambée
irlandaise il ya tout juste dix ans
lorsque catholiques et protestants
s'affrontaient tragiquement à la face du
monde
ces enfants de belfast ont 10 ans l'âge
de la violence en irlande du nord
voilà dix ans en effet que le
gouvernement de londres a envoyé ses
troupes en ulster pour tenter de mettre
fin au conflit
elles n'en sont jamais ressorti au
contraire l'armée britannique s'est
enfoncé elle aussi dans ce bourbier
irlandais qui mobilise les enfants comme
les adultes qui se bat contre qui en
gros les catholiques qui représentent
souvent les couches les plus
défavorisées contre les protestants qui
sont la majorité et restent favorables à
l'alliance avec l'angleterre entre les
deux l'armée britannique
quinze mille hommes la cible des gosses
des quartiers catholiques chargé
d'empêcher les affrontements mais qui
fait face elle aussi aux attentats de
l'ira l'ira l'armée républicaine
irlandaise est infiltrée dans tous les
milieux et se sert souvent des enfants
pour passer des armes ou des bombes
depuis 69 le conflit d'irlande du nord a
fait plus de dix mille morts
les troubles entre communautés les
attentats de l'ira se sont multipliés
jusqu'au jour de cette manifestation où
les vert et noir
les militants de l'organisation
clandestine ont bravé dans les rues de
londres les autorités britanniques
ils étaient plus de 6000 ce jour de mars
72 à protester contre la décision de
l'angleterre de gouverner directement
l'irlande du nord en tête des
manifestants la fameuse bernadette des
villes la pasionaria de l'ulster
attentats explosions alerte à la bombe
l'ira l'armée républicaine irlandaise a
tenu en haleine irlandais et
britanniques
jusqu'au jour de 74 ou l'organisation
clandestine a décidé de porter le
conflit au delà de ses frontières et de
frapper des personnalités britanniques
l'attentât le plus spectaculaire a été
le meurtre de christopher edward
ambassadeur de grande-bretagne à dublin
en irlande du sud pour les commandos de
l'ira l'armée républicaine irlandaise
lord mountbatten n'étaient ainsi qu'un
numéro sur une longue liste d'homme à
abattre
oui cette île à cause des extrémistes
irlandais catholiques ne sort pas grandi
de l'attentât d'hier les gens qu'à
minerai en vous disant que les obsèques
de l'amiral lord man blonde mad men
pardon ont lieu le 5 septembre c'est à
dire mercredi prochain dans l'abbaye de
westminster dans le coeur de londres
un dossier que nous refermons ce soir
maintenant celui de la sphère vla sauva
c'est donc fini la femme du danseur
étoile
alexandre godounov elle-même ballerine
au bolchoï est bien arrivé tout à
l'heure à moscou accueillis par des
fleurs et vous allez le voir par sa mère
il pas se jeter dans ses bras les
soviétiques se déclare révolté par
l'attitude américaine
en revanche à washington dans l'espère
dirigeants d'une manière générale dans
l'opinion publique on n'est pas
mécontent d'avoir tenu bon face aux
soviétiques sur ce point capital des
droits de l'homme propose maintenant
l'analyse de jacques sigui au moment du
départ de l'unine al assad dans sa large
majorité l'opinion publique pensait que
ludmila va sauva mise en présence des
négociateurs américains demanderait
l'autorisation de rejoindre son mari
il n'en est rien alexander gould 9 qui
dit on a agi dans un grand état
d'excitation
au moment où il a pris sa décision good
enough apparaît dans un premier temps
comme le grand perdant de cette affaire
les américains pour leur part sont
conscients d'avoir fait respecter leur
loi et le président carter d'avoir suite
aux nues son grand attachement aux
principes des droits de l'homme
officiellement les américains ont obtenu
l'assurance que la ballerine rentrait à
moscou de son plein gré un médecin
accompagné l'américain mckenry au moment
où ce dernier a rencontré loup 2009 la
sauva à bord d'un camion navette ranger
aux côtés de l'avion soviétique
les américains voulaient en effet
s'assurer que ludmila n'était pas
droguée seuls quelques confrères
soviétiques ont pu rencontrer la
ballerine voici le témoignage de l'un
d'entre eux face à la crise cela dit que
l'autre de sa propre volonté qu'elle
veut revoir les soviétiques l'union
soviétique et sa mère chérie la official
et de didonne officiellement on n'a pas
parlé du mari mais son mari reste ici on
en a vraiment vous parler est les
vallées elle a dit qu'elle ne voulait
voir personne garder ses soeurs official
comme envoyer sa déclaration officielle
mais pas de regrets de quitter son mari
non pas du tout il ne restait plus après
cela à l'avion de l'aeroflot qu'à
s'envoler vers moscou après trois jours
pleins d'une attente imprévu il reste
alexander godounov la vedette du bolchoï
à faire valoir ses talents à new york
un événement qui pourrait se traduire
très rapidement avec l'américain theater
en bref maintenant et toujours à
l'étranger la mort de l'écrivain
soviétique konstantin simonov le
durcissement des règles de l'art au mini
face aux kurdes aucune concession
particulière a dit le chef religieux de
rome et puis il annonce par helsinki de
la future visite du président giscard
d'estaing en finlande au printemps
prochain
voilà qui nous amène aux affaires
françaises et tout d'abord à ce sujet
qui va passionner les français dont une
bonne partie en train d'achever des
vacances la sécurité routière un conseil
administrés lié à matignon le conseil
des ministres demain à l'elysée les
mesures sont prêtes d'ores et déjà plus
de pitié pour les chauffards une
attitude dictée apparemment par la forte
augmentation du nombre des accidents et
des tués sur la route + 10 % en un an
pour le mois de juillet alors à quoi
faut-il s'attendre à pons de laurent
massardier
avec un 1er août en milieu de semaine et
un ton plutôt favorable on n'a pas connu
cette année de rue et spectaculaire pour
le départ en vacances
même chose pour les retours grâce aux
conseils de bison futé bien suivie dans
leur ensemble de l'envoi de
perturbations on a roulé d'une manière
satisfaisante et le bilan par rapport à
encore une fois est favorable ces
perturbations il faut quand même le dire
se sont situés en particulier sur la
nationale 10 entre bayonne bordeaux
angoulême et poitiers
ainsi que dans la vallée du rhône au sud
de lyon sur l'autoroute du soleil
je tiens à préciser de ce côté là que de
très nombreuses perturbations de très
nombreux bouchons routiers sont
consécutifs à des accidents de la
circulation donc pour les retours je
conseille les derniers retours
je conseille aux automobilistes de faire
preuve de la plus extrême prudence en
juillet 79 il y a eu 118 morts et 1600
24 blessés de plus qu'en juillet 78
parmi les causes principales
la fatigue le mauvais état de certains
véhicules avec bon nombres d'éclatement
de pneus l'alcool également et surtout
les excès de vitesse
à ce propos le ministre de l'intérieur
christian bonnet a souligné pour les
jours et semaines à venir
le renforcement de la sévérité à
l'encontre des contrevenants
depuis le 25 juin dernier les contrôles
ont été multipliés trente-deux mille
procès verbaux dressés et plus de 4000
permis retirés ou suspendus aux côtés de
m
en temps ordinaire quoi n'importe quoi
moi je pense du problème puisque je
roule à 90 c'est le maximum qu'elle peut
tirer donc problème pour permis et nous
sommes tombés sur un bouchon il y avait
au moins cinq accidents des accidents
matériels ce n'était pas simple enfin si
je pense que si les gens avaient ralenti
ça ne se serait pas produit est-ce qu'il
ya plus de contrôles de sécurité en
france - hollande à propos je pense dans
un land ça ce dandy servent beaucoup
plus dans toute l'europe
or il vient le but lors du match qui est
effectivement peu encourageant parce que
malgré le travail accru la gendarmerie
dans ses contrôles de vitesse elle a
fait là cette gendarmerie près du double
de contrôle en juillet sont 19 par
rapport à l'époque de 118 nous avons
constaté sur notre réseau une
augmentation alarmant de 11% de victime
je parle les tuer il ya donc été décidé
de continuer de renforcer si possible et
nous ferons ces cantons de vitesse parce
que lorsque l'on analyse les raisons de
ces accidents est ses victimes
on constate que la raison numéro un
c'est précisément la vitesse excessive
je veux dire 30% je dis bien 30%
les accidents corporels sont dus à une
vitesse excessive ayant créé également
30 % de tués
gears of war mal que nous agissions sur
la vitesse excessive puisqu'elle est la
raison principale des accidents
corporels
va-t-on de nouveau abaissé les
limitations de vitesse sur les routes
le conseil des ministres présentera
demain son plan anti chauffard ce plan
prévoirait l'augmentation du taux d
amende inchangé depuis 1975
les automobilistes devraient les payer
sur-le-champ sinon elle pourrait être
augmentée du simple au double enfin les
retrait ou suspension de permis de
conduire serait facilitée oui des
meilleurs qui je vous le rappelle l'ong
seront officiellement en prise demain à
l'issue du conseil un conseil qui sera
essentiellement consacré aux mesures
économiques et sociales en faveur des
plus déshérités
le gouvernement veut en effet atténuée
au moins partiellement l'augmentation
récente des charges sur le pouvoir
d'achat des plus démunis alors cela
concernera surtout les familles à
revenus modestes et les personnes âgées
pour le domaine social dure également un
volet économique avec des décisions en
matière de logement de travaux publics
et d'économie d'énergie
je pense que là aussi il nous faut
attendre demain pour avoir des
certitudes
en attendant la politique économique de
raymond barre continue de faire l'objet
d'un tir de barrage nourri ce matin par
une salve de michel debré qui a annoncé
qu'il ne voterait pas le budget de 1980
si on ne change pas et si vraiment le
parlement doit avoir un budget qui lui
est présenté avec 40 milliards de
déficit c'est à dire plus qu'il y a l'an
dernier plus qu'il ya deux ans et bien
cela signifie vais lui est arrivé elle
voter mais non pas plus que celui de
l'an dernier
puis le problème n'est plus un problème
parlementer le problème est vraiment
poser à la france et aux français
est-ce que nous allons continuer sur une
voie qui montre que 1979 est moins
brillante 78 et qui nous assure que 80
soit moins brillante 1979
est-ce qu'on va continuer à dire aux
français le bout du tunnel est proche
français 35 heures par semaine et vous
gagnerez la guerre et michel devresse
souhaite je le cite placer la france
dans le camp des vainqueurs c'est ce
qu'il disait sur notre antenne donc tout
à l'heure à 12h45
puisque nous parlons de politique sachez
que le parti communiste répondra demain
proposition de rencontre des socialistes
et que les deux techniciens qui avait
réalisé fin juin à l'émission pirates du
ps radio riposte sont à leur tour
convoqués par le juge d'instruction pour
le 6 septembre
mais pour l'heure le débat politique du
moment tourne autour de cette question -
d'ado nine qu'il y paraît défense
européenne ou défense de l'europe
l'interrogation date pas d'aujourd'hui
mais elle a été relancée par deux prises
de position spectaculaire voici dix
jours dans le nouvel observateur
celle d'alexandre sanguinetti et du
général puisqu'ils se sont prononcés
pour une défense européenne organisée
autour d'une alliance franco-allemande
le débat a pris une telle proportion que
l'elysée a tenu ce matin faire une mise
au point
les propos des uns et des autres dit on
l'abat n'affecte pas la politique de la
france
cette politique s'exprime par des
déclarations du président et du
gouvernement et pierre unc le porte
parole de l'elysée d'insister sur
l'importance des moyens mis au service
du développement de la défense
indépendante de la france alors je crois
que le copain qu'il faut revenir un
petit peu sur la genèse de ce débat
vieux comme je disais tout à l'heure
c'est un très vieux débat qui remonte à
il ya quelques 25 ans qui curieusement
n'avait pas eu lieu d'ailleurs pendant
la campagne des élections européennes
et il vient de ressurgir cet été il y eu
d'abord la publication d'un livre euro
shima ses auteures deux militaires deux
officiers et un professeur et son thème
la défense européenne est possible il
faut la vouloir
alors qu'il ya tout ça il ya tout un
débat stratégique d'abord il y à des
fins stratégiques et je crois que ce
débat finalement et surtout relancé par
la sphère et les accords salt 2 conclu
entre les américains et les russes les
pays européens depuis ces accords se
sentent moins à l'abri de ce qu'on
appelait le bouclier européen car il est
vrai que les américains cherchent
surtout à protéger leur propre
territoire national et puis les
révolutions techniques qui est
importante
à la suite de ces accords les américains
et les russes m'ont donné une nouvelle
impulsion à leur fabrication d'armements
plutôt nouvelle orientation au terme de
laquelle ces armements nucléaires
pourront viser de façon beaucoup plus
précise les objectifs militaires et non
plus comme le disent publiquement
d'autres fois les objectifs
démographique
ce qui veut dire que pour rester
crédible une force de dissuasion comme
la force de dissuasion française devrait
suivre
elle aussi cette évolution ce qui
coûterait fort cher d'où la recherche
d'un partenaire et d'une entente qui
permettrait de poursuivre cette
évolution coûteuse à raser le carreau
stratégique et delà d'une implication
politique bien oui tout cela se greffent
bien sûr sur un certain climat politique
français une vieille
querelles donc et qui se rallument de
temps en temps communistes et une partie
des décos liste reprochant au président
de la république de vouloir abandonner
la doctrine gaulliste d'une défense
vraiment indépendante et de glisser
doucement vers une défense européenne
l'attitude du président de la république
était définie par lui-même en 1975 elle
revient en gros à ceci il faut d'abord
construire une europe politique
indépendante avant d'envisager d'avoir
une défense proprement européenne
le problème c'est donc le processus où
les inverse de celui qui a été proposé
il ya quelques 25 ans leur part les
partisans de la communauté européenne de
défense la fameuse cd on peut dire je
crois que le problème de la défense de
l'europe est un vieux problème qui reste
posée et qui restera posée sans doute
encore longtemps le général vis parlait
d'ailleurs lui-même d'une ou deux
décennies bien je vous laisse elle
espérait tout à l'heure des premières
images de l'attentât de bruxelles et
viennent d'arriver à l'instant vous
allez voir il s'agit d'un document tout
à fait exceptionnelle puisque tournée
par un amateur qui était à touristes
qu'ils voyaient était en train de filmer
un édifice de la grand place et tout
d'un coup vous allez le voir l'explosion
avec évidemment la surprise du caméraman
amateur qui voit cette explosion qui je
vous le rappelle a fait une dizaine de
personnes dont
six militaires britanniques blessés deux
de ses militaires qui étaient des
soldats de la fanfare du régiment du duc
d'edimbourg sont d'ailleurs dans un état
grave ce soir l'attentât je vous le
rappelle a été revendiquée tout à fait
en fin d'après-midi par l'ira l'ira donc
cette organisation d'autonomistes
irlandais catholiques qui avait
revendiqué l'attentât contre lord
mountbatten voici donc ces premières
images qui ne sont arrivés il ya
quelques secondes seulement de bruxelles
décidément les sous sols des banques de
la société générale fa tir de bien
curieux clients des élèves en herbe
d'albert spaggiari ses instigateurs du
vol spectaculaire des coffres de la
société générale de nice à paris
aujourd'hui la brigade anti gang a mis
fin à une nouvelle tentative de ce genre
elle a arrêté la main dans le sac huit
hommes qui creusait un tunnel en
direction des codes de la société
générale située rue de sèvres dans le 6e
arrondissement
c'est par ce trou difficilement percée
dans la maçonnerie d'un égout
désaffectée sous les caves du 8 de la
rue de sèvres que les émules de
spaggiari compte et accéder aux murs
blindé de la salle des mille coffres de
la société générale sèvres babylone
mais aujourd'hui les 8 rue en
curieusement moins actif depuis quelques
jours et est cueilli par 50 policiers
qui planquaient depuis 4 heures du matin
sous la direction de plusieurs brigades
dont les anti gang de paris et de nice
où le coût a été préparée voici
plusieurs mois
sur place les faux et goûter était
déguisé en techniciens edf pratiquant un
raccordement la concierge confié donc de
bonne foi à la clé de la case
quant aux policiers ils étaient
également en salopette bleue rarement on
a vu autant de bleu de travail dans ce
quartier de magasins chics
ce matin donc 8h18 paire de menottes
claqué les systèmes d'alarmé des parois
de la salle des coffres n'ont même pas
été inquiétés
depuis 4-5 mois la mairie de nice de mon
collègue maureillas et labeyrie de paris
nous avons travaillé sur une équipe de
malfaiteurs qui préparaient une grosse
affaire style de société générale de
nice et nous en avons interpellé huit ce
matin
principaux mais est ce que ce sont des
truands connu certains oui la plupart
très calmes très froid très pondéré
jamais je récuse cela n'avait eu aucun
soupçon il travaillait franchement
douceur sans lever très correcte avec
les gens depuis qu'on puisse du flagrant
délit ces casseurs sont quinze au total
parisien italien eni soit impliqué dans
des dossiers politiques et parfois
proche d'albert spaggiari dont l'ombre
plane donc maintenant sur cette
tentative
oui autre hold up qui lui est allé à son
terme à la perception compte sur
l'escroc condé-sur-l'escaut près de
valenciennes plus de 10 millions de
francs c'est une somme record ont été
volés par six malfaiteurs dont une femme
les bandits étaient bien renseignés
puisque l'argent des pensions venait
tout juste d'arriver à cette perception
donc de condé sur l'escaut d'arbres
rebondissement dans la sphère de la
ferme ensorcelé roger la horse dire le
fils du propriétaire la ferme et michèle
jauss candau sa compagne après avoir été
entendu hier par le juge d'instruction
ont été aujourd'hui écroués l'un à la
prison de tarbes l'autre à celle de pau
va donc qui met sens dessus dessous les
hypothèses échafaudées jusqu alors sur
cette affaire bien mystérieuse mais pas
si diabolique que ça le diable semble
désormais hors de cause dans cette
affaire michel josserand d'eau 18 ans
ici sur ces images sortant du palais de
justice de tares et rochers lahore 29
ans sont passés aux aveux hier dans la
nuit les chefs d'inculpation n'ont
toujours pas été précisé mais pour les
enquêteurs
une partie du mystère et éclaircies le
phénomène de combustion spontanée ne
serait rien d'autre qu'une poudre à base
de sodium ou de potassium s'enflammer au
contact de l'air ou de l'eau
quant au mobile de ses 81 18 incendies
dont le premier remonte au 6 août
dernier il reste encore à déterminer
il pourrait s'agir d'une histoire
d'héritage qui aurait profondément
divisé la famille de la houle c'est sans
doute ce qui explique que les quatre
autres membres de la famille ont été
placés en garde à vue et entendus tout
l'après midi par le juge d'instruction
aucune magie noire donc à séron la ferme
des lao
or a pourtant connu les feux de
l'actualité pendant trois semaines quant
aux apprentis sorciers
à force de jouer avec le feu ils auront
fini par s'y brûler photographie et vie
privée maintenant vous savez que l'un
des moyens envisagés récemment pour
limiter les agressions contre des
chauffeurs de taxi prévoyait
l'installation dans les véhicules
d'appareils chargé de photographier
systématiquement chaque client d'un
procédé coûteux dont l'efficacité n'a
apparemment pas convaincu les chauffeurs
de taxi s'agit d'un autre tout autre
autre domaine c'est un procédé déjà
largement utilisé dans de nombreuses
grandes surfaces pour parer aux
possibles d'agression est aussi dépister
les chèques volés mais en systématisant
ce genre de pratiques ne va-t-on pas
multiplier les atteintes à la vie privée
l'enquète de jean marc loos on ne vous
demandera pas forcément de sourire quand
vous passerez à la caisse mais ici vous
serez photographier
du moins si le montant de votre chèque
est supérieur à 500 francs une méthode
de plus en plus répandu pour lutter
contre l'utilisation frauduleuse de
chéquiers volés ou prétendument volés
avec ce procédé photo échec porteront un
même numéro d'achat mais si chacun reste
libre de refuser la faute aux contrôles
peu de clients semble-t-il voire une
atteinte à leur vie privée
cela vous gêne-t-il d'être photographiée
quand vous faites un paiement par chèque
absolument pas j'ai la conscience
tranquille ici on accueille quinze mille
clients par jour en 73 120 millions de
francs de marchandises payés avec des
chèques volés dissuasion oblige on a
choisi de photographier le client les
pertes ne sont plus que de 40 millions
par an mais que deviennent ces milliers
de photos fiches la pellicule est
détruite
un mois après
l'établissement du chef
une réponse qui se veut rassurante mais
il faut savoir que la destruction de la
pellicule impressionné ne fait l'objet
d'aucun contrôle légal rien n'exclut
donc le danger de constitution
clandestine de fichiers à des fins
commerciales politiques ou autres
photographes y ait quelqu'un sans son
consentement
c'est toujours est licite si c'est dans
un lieu privé c'est même délit pénal si
c'est dans un lieu public
ça reste une infraction à la loi civile
et à la jurisprudence des tribunaux
moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est que d'une
part on tend à donner aux citoyens le
sentiment qu'on renforce leurs droits
individuels leurs droits personnels et
c'était l'objet affiché de la loi du 17
juillet 1970 et d'autre part on tend les
habitués à cette idée que sous un
prétexte sécurité l'ordre public ou tout
simplement la sécurité des transactions
commerciales
il doit vous renoncé à ses droits qu'on
leur a reconnu on le reprend d'une main
ce qu'on fait semblant de leur donner de
l'autre c'est tout le problème
efficacité rentabilité au sécurité
simple face aux caméras de surveillance
se sont chaque jour peut-être des petits
morceaux de liberté qui sont géniaux t
il serait bon que les législateurs lui
aussi y regarde d'un peu plus près états
unis general motors vers la première
firme automobile américaine condamnée à
verser 2 millions 500 mille dollars aux
parents d'un jeune homme mort dans un
accident de voiture la voiture avaient
été reconnus dangereux
le réservoir était placé trop près et il
y a donc vous le voyez ce jugement assez
étonnant d'une cour américaine qui
condamne à deux millions cinq cent mille
dollars
la firme general motors va jouer promis
hier voici maintenant la suite de nos
enquêtes sur le bilan des vacances si
hier vous avez pu suivre nos conclusions
pour le midi méditerranéen ce soir avec
une douce à la normale s'est inscrit
dans l'histoire et dans les habitudes ce
qui plonge dormantes pense aujourd'hui
débarquement en fait deux choses d'une
part un côté traditionnellement beau
choix et même un peu plus de l'autre un
côté plus populaires comment sont si
vous voulez bien par le secteur
attraction je ne trouve pas d'autres
mots pour ce qui est des retombées des
grands événements historiques et de leur
exploitation touristique qu'il s'agisse
de verdun ou de la normandie comment ça
se passe et le débarquement chez vous
c'est la zone par rapport aux années
précédentes et disons autant non mais
disons des gens beaucoup moins argentés
c'est tout un
et avec le temps que nous a pas
favorisés au mois d'août disons les gens
restent non beaucoup moins longtemps que
les années passées dans tout un peu
privilégié ici avec l'élevage du
débarquement voilà et on dise on
al'avantage d'avoir le musée qui se
trouve cela derrière nous je sais sur la
place nous apporte beaucoup d'étrangers
belge boulet américains hollandais mêmes
allemands pour nous disent on
al'avantage de se trouver à cette heure
ensemble le spanc
et puis plus proches de l'estuaire de la
seine s'il ya dont ville qui ne paraît
pas affecter par l' indice des prix
trouville un cran en dessous semble plus
sensible aux fluctuations du baromètre
monétaire de ce fait par les temps qui
courent à deux heures de route de paris
cet endroit se révèle être une sorte de
route secours pour vacanciers parisiens
en mal d'air du large pour un dégagement
de dernière minute avec tout ce que cela
comporte de restriction qu'il faut
savoir lire entre les lignes je peux
vous dire que nous avons eu à trouver
une bonne saison dans l'ensemble mais
qui ne laissera pas quand même un
sourire un souvenir impérissable
le millésime 79 n'étant pas d'une
notoriété peu particulière y compris ne
sera pas le grand cru néanmoins on a
connu une très bonne fréquentation
pendant le mois de juillet et vu les
conditions climatiques un petit peu
défavorable en où la fréquentation était
un peu moins abondants que d'habitude la
clientèle en ce congé
on a remarqué cette année un
développement notre clientèle étrangère
en particulier cette clientèle qui vient
du benelux de l'allemagne enfin tous les
pays qui sont au nord et en plus je
dirai à mon et forte
mais enfin si on fait un petit lieu
bilan les anglais restent toujours en
tête suivi maintenant de très près par
les allemands puis les hollandais et les
belges c'est le fond ce dans l'histoire
un petit peu comme partout on peut être
une certaine morosité il certaines
inquiétudes d'une peur de l'avenir qui
les a obligés à peut-être regarder de
plus près cette année ça marche
en vérité ce que l'on constate à dos
vivait à trouville c'est une sorte de
démocratisation du joint de
vulgarisation on le constate à regret
son vouloir l'avouer à voix haute
donc julliard isation de saison doit
traditionnellement chic d'un côté et
bourgeois de l'ocs
bon je me suis même laissé dire que mimi
les nénettes descendait de banlieue
parisienne pour jouer aux boules et que
les turfistes se faisaient aujourd'hui
davantage remarqué par le saucisson et
le rond rouge que par le chapeau claque
et vous me direz que cela c'est
peut-être davantage une question
d'évolution sociale que de conjoncture
économique
oui ça c'est un reportage signé louis
doucet à la limite du sport à nouveau
record du monde réalisé par des
spéléologues ça s'est passé dans la
drôme dans réseau de bourne ou 16 180
mètres ont été explorées ancien record
15 136 m autre exploit mais dans les
verres je vous avais montré hier soir
les images de ce britannique qui voulait
réaliser son rêve londres paris en
deltaplane à moteur et bien c'est fait
nous nous voyons ici atterrir à
saint-cyr-l'ecole près de paris lui aura
fallu quatre jours une aile de 9 mètres
d'envergure et un moteur de
tronçonneuses de 125 centimètres cubes
une deuxième aile volante piloté par un
autre britannique de 53 ans et qui
voulait réaliser le même exploit a dû
renoncer bien tristement pour une raison
très prosaïque son elle n'était pas
immatriculée les gendarmes ont mis face
au voyage voilà avant de refermer tout à
fait journal la météo aujourd'hui il a
fait beau pratiquement sur l'ensemble du
pays les températures vous avez pu le
remarquer et est en légère hausse pour
demain et bien la météo nous annonce eu
à peu près le même temps alex pendant
une tendance orageuse qui se développera
dans l'après-midi près des pyrénées et
en corse
voilà ce journal est maintenant terminée
vous avez rendez vous vers 23h30 avec
hervé claude pour le tout dernier
journal et puis demain à lydie avec
daniel bilalian à 12h45 pour antenne
2010 bonne soirée à tous
à demain soir